(plane rattling)
- He's not even flight crew.
He's an airplane technician.
I mean, come one.
That's it, and he
talks too much.
That's why I like you. You
don't talk, you just listen.
That's good. Oh.
(bell chimes)
okay.
And the captain has turned
on the fasten seat belt sign.
Got a little turbulence comin'
up, should be no problem.
Just remain in your seat
until the sign is turned off.
Thank you for your cooperation.
Okay.
(seatbelt rustling)
- Excuse me, I'm gonna
go to the bathroom.
- Hi.
Excuse me.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna need you
to take your seat.
The fasten seat belt sign is on.
- I'm just gonna go to
the bathroom for a second.
I'll be right back, okay?
- I understand
what you wanna do.
Unfortunately I'm gonna need you
to observe the fasten
seat belt sign.
That'd be much appreciated.
- Right, it's just I
read on the internet
that it's not against the law
for me to go to the bathroom
while the fasten seat
belt sign is on, so.
- Seat belt sign is on.
- But is it against
the law, though?
- The light is on.
- Is it against the law?
- You see that there's a picture
of a seat belt on that sign?
- I know, but is it
against the law, though?
- The fasten seat
belt sign is on.
- But is it against
the law, though?
- Sir, the seat belt sign's on.
- But is it against the law?
- Seat belt sign is on.
- Seat belt sign.
- But is it against the law?
- It's on.
- Law?
- Seat belt sign is on.
- Legal?
- Lawful?
- Seat belt sign is on.
- Sir, you're being difficult.
- Law.
- You're being very difficult.
- Law. Law.
Law. Law.
- Seat belt. Seat belt.
- Not illegal. Not illegal.
- Not illegal.
- Okay.
- Legal.
- Fasten
- Fasten your seat
- Legal.
- Sir?
- I have to piss and I have
to (beep) in the toilet.
- Sir, can you lower your voice?
- I have to piss
and I have to (beep)
- Okay, lower your intensity.
- You're louder than me.
You're
- You're yelling in my face
Sir you're the one who I
think needs to tone it down
right now, you are
screaming at me.
- You're hurting my ear drums.
- That wasn't a word, you're
not saying a word there.
- This is a word.
- That's not
- That's a word
- That's not a word,
that's a tongue trick.
Okay, sir, sir, sir?
If you would like
- I would not like to.
I would not like to sit down.
What I'd like to do, is go
take (beep) in the bathroom.
Because it's not
against the law.
So I'm going to to go
to the bathroom, okay?
Mark, with a K.
(deep breaths)
(suspenseful music)
(plane lightly shaking)
(seatbelt clicks)
(plane shaking)
(passengers gasping)
(plane roaring)
(plane shaking)
(engine roaring)
(passengers screaming)
(crashing)
(suspenseful music)
(plane shaking)
(engine roaring)
(thuds)
(plane shaking)
(engine roaring)
(passengers screaming)
(groans)
(suspenseful music)
(door opens)
(engine roaring)
(passengers screaming)
(thuds)
(machine beeping)
(passengers screaming)
(intense music)
(plane rocking)
(suspenseful music)
(head thuds)
(seatbelt clicking)
(sighs of relief)
(sign beeps)
(sighs)
- And your captain has turned
off the fasten seat belt sign
feel free to move
around the cabin.
Thank you for your cooperation.
(intense music)